et selon bastien richesse trésorier de
génération point s le gouvernement
manque de transparence sur sa stratégie
vaccinale on l'écouté pourquoi on a
attendu à ce point avant de mettre on a
justement des lacs six nations plus rage
peut-être que là la réponse est dû
coûter encore une fois de l'anticipation
et du manque d'anticipation auprès du
gouvernement
moi je suis heureux qu'on puisse
maintenant avancer que justement les la
campagne puisse vraiment commencé mais
que les premiers rendez-vous de cette
semaine montre que justement priori le
gouvernement a décidé de changer de
braquet comme on dit sur 7 sur cette
campagne de vaccination on attend quand
même qu on ait des réponses très
précises sur la capacité à vacciner dans
les prochaines semaines et puis qu'on
nous donne également des horizons mais
en terme de mental de stratégie de
vaccination c'est qu'il ya d'autres
vaccins qui doivent arriver ce serait je
serai bien effectivement on est con et
c'est cette vision là en tout cas que la
campagne de vaccination avance et que le
plus de nombre de personnes possibles
puissent être vacciné je crois que c'est
une évidence absolue dans la mesure où
on a véritablement besoin de d'arrêter
avec ce cycle infernal de confinement
est trop beaux cheveux qui sont autant
de difficultés pour prononcer la société
pour l'économie française